[Musique]
et puis depuis hier soir nouvelle
spectaculaire victimes de l'austérité
l'aérotrain qui devait relier la défense
à cergy pontoise
le projet a tout simplement été
abandonnée l'aérotrain cergy la défense
ne sera pas construit le projet est
abandonné nouvelle victime de la
politique d'austérité du gouvernement
la décision de construire une ligne
rapide entre la ville nouvelle de
pontoise cergy et le quartier de la
défense avaient été prises en 1971
c'est la technique du coussin d'air
appliquée aux véhicules de transport en
commun et expérimenté à orléans qui
avait été retenu pour les 26 kilomètres
du projet
deux raisons majeures à ce choix assurer
nos liaisons pratique avec une ville
nouvelle
pôle d'attraction de la région
parisienne est présenté aux étrangers
plusieurs pays sont intéressés par le
système
une ligne dans des conditions réelles
d'exploitation
très vite pourtant des difficultés
étaient apparus surtout dans la mise au
point du mode de propulsion choisi le
moteur électrique linéaire de conception
révolutionnaire le moteur linéaire ne
pouvait être prêt avant 5 en difficulté
aussi avec les riverains notamment dans
les yvelines qui se plaignait de voir
passer un aéro train coupant les
communes en 2 sans pour autant en
bénéficier ces difficultés ont donc eu
raison d'un projet contesté retardé et
dont le coût suivez les augmentations 12
ordres on l'estimait déjà cette année à
600 millions de francs
il reste à l'ingénieur bertin père de
l'aérotrain et du coussin d'air à
trouver d'autres applications pour son
système en france et hors des frontières
dès à présent ils s'y emploient
convaincu dit-il de défendre une
technique d'avenir
[Musique]